All right, you're done.
Let's take a look at the solution.
Adding support for the location
insert looks almost identical
to adding the support for weather.
We just have to select the right table
name, and return the right location URI.
Remember, at the end of the function,
we can just call notify change on
the content resolver to notify
all of the registered observers.
Note that we must use the past in URI,
and not the return URI,
as that will not correctly notify
our cursors of the change.
Since we also uncommented
test insert read provider,
let's run our test just to make sure
everything's still working well.
Note that nothing appears
on device screen.
And, our test passed.
We're well on our way to
building our content provider.